[Musique]
les énergies renouvelables
rentrent-elles dans une nouvelle ère on
en parle avec vous Xavier Barbaro
bonjour bonjour David
producteur indépendant français vous le
préciser d'énergie renouvelable
essentiellement d'ailleurs
on est on fait aussi de l'éolien en
France comme ailleurs mais en France on
a vraiment un ex solaire et en
particulier agricolaire au 3/4 on voit
que le gouvernement va accélérer sur les
renouvelables et j'ai envie de dire
est-ce que vous aussi quel que soit
l'issue du projet de loi qui discutait
actuellement par Le Mans
écoutez nous on a vraiment des gens on a
fait beaucoup de choses on a envie d'en
faire encore plus on pense que le
solaire est une très bonne solution pour
l'avenir énergétique de la France on a
de la place on a du soleil on a des
capitaux on a du savoir-faire on a des
industriels qui savent construire des
centrales solaires donc ça pourrait
vraiment être un Game changer pour la
France mais il y a des freins à lever
il y a des freins levés et en même temps
le gouvernement semble avoir l'intention
de les lever donc il faut que les
procédures aillent plus vite il faut que
les que les administrations peut-être
comprennent mieux ce qu'on fait il y a
peut-être encore une forme
d'apprentissage mais il y a pas de frein
finalement autre que cela ce qui est
déjà une bonne nouvelle on entend
souvent que le solaire est une énergie
qui est ultra compétitive est-ce que
vous avez des chiffres qui sont
indiscutables là-dessus et notamment on
pense par rapport au nucléaire
qu'on a de court terme sur le nucléaire
évidemment par exemple les derniers
appels d'offre gouvernementaux en France
alors ça dépend de la taille des projets
ça dépend leur localisation mais
typiquement on sait faire des électrons
solaires à 60 70 euros par pour donner
des repères aujourd'hui les marchés
spots les marchés de l'électricité en
France c'est quasiment 8 dix fois ça le
nouveau nucléaire c'est une fois et demi
ça en termes de prix et l'ancienne
nucléaire donc complètement amorti
c'était à peu près les deux tiers de ça
mais nous-mêmes quand nos centrales
solaires seront amortis le coût de
production marginal puisqu'on a pas
vraiment de de matière première à payer
sera très bas donc c'est une énergie qui
est ultra compétitive qui est compétitif
qui est évidemment verte qui est
souveraine puisque une fois que la
centrale est construite en France elle
va produire de l'électricité made in
France pendant 30 ans même si c'est
composant sont pas tous français et puis
c'est une électricité évidemment qui qui
est locale donc en circuit court voilà
et donc l'idée c'est de ne plus être
dépendant on le voit bien en matière des
géopolitiques notamment du gaz russe
mais ce qu'on ne risque pas et c'est là
le sujet de basculer d'une dépendance
russe on pense par rapport au gaz et une
dépendance chinoise et vous me voyez
venir parce qu'aujourd'hui les panneaux
solaires ils sont dans leur grande
majorité produites en Chine les vôtres
leçons d'ailleurs aussi ils sont pas le
temps de majorité produit en Chine
aujourd'hui
on pourrait tout à fait en Europe et
d'ailleurs il y a des projets
réinternaliser la production de panneaux
solaires le savoir-faire historiquement
il est plutôt européen il était même
assez allemand aujourd'hui quand on
visite une usine de panneaux solaires en
Chine ce qui m'est arrivé à plusieurs
reprises on voit que les machines qui
fabriquent ces panneaux sont européennes
et ce sont des
usines qui sont très automatisées les
Chinois finalement sont devenus bons
dans la production de panneaux solaires
par effet d'échelle mais on pourrait
tout à fait refaire ça en Europe neon
soutient cette idée on a nous-mêmes
signé des lettres des lettres
d'engagement auprès d'un certain nombre
de d'usines qui aimeraient exister en
France et en Europe pour nous montrer
qu'on en serait volontiers clients la
part de la valeur ajoutée dans un
panneau solaire lié aux cellules
fabriquées en Chine qu'est-ce que ça
représente aujourd'hui quand vous avez
une centrale solaire quand vous
investissez son et à peu près 35 40 qui
vont dans les panneaux ce qui veut dire
que la majorité donc on achète à la
Chine même si aujourd'hui on achète
aujourd'hui à la Chine mais qu'on
pourrait tout aussi bien acheter à des
dans des usines europ
si elles sont construites le reste donc
la majorité aujourd'hui c'est du contenu
assez largement français et européen
vous avez les structures métalliques
vous avez les équipements électriques
vous avez évidemment tout le génie civil
et l'ingénierie où il y a des très
bonnes entreprises françaises donc
aujourd'hui une centrale solaire même
quand vous voyez des panneaux qui sont
made in China vous avez à l'intérieur du
Bouygues du Nexon du harcelor donc vous
avez un vrai contenu français et
européen mais si on si on relocalise la
production encore une fois d'une
centrale solaire en France on se dit
qu'il faudra toujours du silicium le
silicium pardon encore une fois ça vient
de chienne non aujourd'hui les les
usines de raffinage de silicium le
silicium c'est la matière première la
plus abondante sur terre donc
aujourd'hui le raffinage du silicium qui
est quelque chose qu'on sait très bien
faire qui nécessite beaucoup
d'électricité là-bas oui on le fait
là-bas mais enfin ils le font là-bas on
pourrait tout aussi bien le faire ici il
y a eu pendant des années des grandes
usines qui étaient par exemple en
Norvège alimenté avec de
l'hydroélectricité en France on a aussi
électricité on pourrait tout à fait
faire des panneaux solaires made in
France mais je pense moi que ça vaut la
peine aujourd'hui d'essayer de
réinternaliser cette production de
panneaux solaires en tout cas ça nous
permettrait d'avoir une chaîne complète
made in Europe et donc en termes
d'approvisionnement d'être complètement
indépendant mais à nouveau même pour un
panneau qu'aujourd'hui on achète en
Chine on met les îles aux États-Unis une
fois qu'il est installé en Corrèze ça
reste de l'électricité made in France
pour les 30 prochaines années après
encore une fois si il coûte plus cher
c'est pas nos photosvoltaïques produits
en France au début peut-être pas à terme
parce qu'il y aura des économies
d'échelle bien sûr est-ce que vous
pourriez vous engager chez Nolwenn ne
plus acheter encore une fois ces
fournisseurs chinois il a joué le jeu la
relocalisation quittaire
on le dit on l'écrit d'ailleurs on a
envoyé des courriers dans nos différents
ministères pour dire qu'on serait
vraiment heureux de payer des panneaux
10 ou 15% plus cher c'est à peu près le
différentiel qu'on estime pour avoir des
panneaux faits en Europe d'abord je
pense que ce serait une belle histoire
je pense aussi que en terme de de chaîne
d'approvisionnement ça nous donnerait
beaucoup de confort plutôt que de le
nombre de containers qui viennent de
Chine etc on sait que on pourrait avoir
accès à nos panneaux plus facilement
donc aujourd'hui ce qu'on sait faire
avec des Chinois on le fera d'autant
plus volontiers avec des Européens il y
a plus de relocalisation justement
aujourd'hui qui vont se sens il y a des
projets
qui existent alors déjà on sent non il y
a des ministres il y a des projets en
France comme en Europe alors il y a eu
cette fausse idée qu'on a entendu qui
est de toute façon la bataille du
panneau solaire était perdue et donc il
fallait se concentrer sur les batteries
ou sur l'hydrogène et c'est très bien
j'espère qu'il y aura en gros le marché
les chinois avait gagné quoi finalement
la bataille et pas du tout et donc le
chinois dans ce dans ce secteur là comme
dans d'autres ont pris de l'avance mais
on peut vraiment retrouver la capacité
industrielle en Europe je pense que
avoir une production domestique de
panneaux solaires comme d'ailleurs une
production domestique de masques
FFP2 ou autre c'est une bonne politique
européenne et une bonne politique
française allez merci Xavier Barbara
merci
renouvelable merci à vous merci tiens
ici pour retrouver notre souv en matière
de panneaux solaires on se passait
carrément du silicium qui est on l'a dit
produit en Chine
[Musique]